au nom du groupe l'est républicain je
veux avant tout saluer la mémoire de
cédric de pierrepont et d'alain bertrand
c'est l'eau et témoigner l'immense
gratitude de la représentation nationale
à leur égard ainsi qu'à l'égard de tous
nos soldats
la france bouleversée a rendu un hommage
solennel à cédric de pierre pons et
alain berton de cello ses héros du
commandant hubert qui avec leurs
camarades ont sauvé des otages touristes
inconscients des dangers qu'il courait
dans cette région du nord bénin ces
soldats ont accompli un exploit
ils l'ont payé de leur vie mais ils ont
aussi montré ainsi que la france
n'abandonne jamais ses enfants
nous ne les oublierons pas et à cet
instant nous pensons à leurs familles à
leurs camarades de combat et à ses
milliers de soldats qui pour notre
compte combattent au sahel pour la
sécurité de l'europe toute entière
alors que le gouvernement se targue
d'une augmentation du pouvoir d'achat en
2019 de retraités sur trois sont
appauvris avec la hausse massive de la
csg et la désindexation des pensions de
retraite
les familles sont également touchées par
une baisse de leur allocation insipide
et hausses de tarifs de l'énergie
les automobilistes qui prennent chaque
jour leur voiture pour aller travailler
subissent une double peine
la hausse du prix du pétrole et la
hausse des taxes
en l'espace de deux ans où la moyenne
européenne établit une augmentation de
18 centimes par litre de gasoil les
français ont dû eux débourser 27
centimes supplémentaires plaçant ainsi
la france comme pays européens où le
prix du gasoil a le plus augmenté depuis
2010 est nous sommes le troisième pays
européen à taxer le plus le gasoil mais
votre gouvernement a écarté le 7 mai
dernier
toute baisse de taxes ou tout retour
d'une taxe flottante
pour rappel sept salariés sur dix se
rendent en voiture sur leur lieu de
travail notamment en milieu rural en
2018 avec les hausses de taxes un
automobiliste faisant un plein de 50
litres de gasoil par semaine à payer 200
euros euros de taxe en plus la
commission européenne paraît déterminé à
conclure au plus vite un accord
commercial avec le mercosur
c'est à dire le brésil
l'argentine l'uruguay et le paraguay le
ministre brésilien du commerce luc
aphérèse vient d'ailleurs de déclarer
qu'un accord n'a jamais été aussi proche
en l'état des négociations cet accord
d'une part conduirait à ce que le
citoyen français consomment plus de
viande ne correspond pas ne
correspondant pas à nos normes
environnementales et sanitaires que nous
imposons à nous mêmes est d'autre part
mettrait nos agriculteurs dans une
situation de concurrence parfaitement
déloyal
la commission fait des choix de plus en
plus singulier dans le monde on peut
légitimement se demander s'il est
raisonnable d'envisager de brader notre
souveraineté alimentaire n'y at il pas
contradiction à faire de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique une priorité
est envisagée en même temps d'importer
des volumes de viande ne répondant à
aucune demande alors que la sagesse et
la cohérence devrait nous amener à
choisir une autre voie
vous aviez promis un choc d'offre c'est
tout le contraire qui se produit la
construction de logements marque le pas
subissant de plein fouet les effets de
votre politique
vous faites fausse route 2018 a connu
des baisses drastiques - 7 % pour les
mises en chantier -7% aussi pour les
permis de construire et cela empire au
premier trimestre 2010 vous aggraver les
fractures territoriales vous freinez à
l'accession à la propriété des jeunes
ménages des classes moyennes déjà bien
malmené par les rabots opéré par votre
politique familiale -28% de prêt à taux
zéro octroyé en un an
c'est considérable le logement
représente pour beaucoup de français la
charge la plus importante de leur budget
25% en moyenne jusqu'à 50% pour les plus
modestes
il convient d'en réduire le coût c'est
donc une question de pouvoir d'achat
or la politique de votre gouvernement
nous remplit guerre ses objectifs quand
allez vous enfin nous écouter quand
allez vous enfin reconsidérer la pierre
comme notre patrimoine commun
quand allez vous enfin mener une
politique du logement à la hauteur des
attentes devant les préoccupations
majeures des français
concerne l'accès aux soins et plus
spécifiquement la possibilité de trouver
un médecin à proximité de leur lieu de
vie il existe sur le territoire national
des régions entières où cette difficulté
d'accès posent un grave est réel
problème de santé publique ce qui nous
scandalise c'est l'absence de prise en
compte du problème dramatique de
désertification médicale dans la
définition du nombre d'étudiants admis à
signer des études de médecine
cela signifie que les déshérités
d'aujourd'hui le seront davantage encore
demain qu'on fait les habitants de ces
régions pourraient être privés un votre
question roi etc essentielle être
correctement soigné
[Musique]